فلسطين سوف تتحرر من النهر إلى
البحر ريتشارد
بار نحن ندعمهم
بشكل مطلق فهل تعترف بأن
المسؤولية النهائية عن
كل خسارة في الأرواح
فظيعة ولكنها هي فشل
الولايات المتحدة والاتحاد الأوروبي في
الغرب  القوى لمحاسبة
إسرائيل على عقود طويلة من
التطهير العرقي وجرائم الحرب ضد
الإنسانية أه إنكار أبسط
حقوق الشعب الفلسطيني
[موسيقى]
الشعب الأيرلندي يفهم غريزيًا أوجه
التشابه بين تاريخه
وتاريخ
الشعب الفلسطيني لأنه  أيرلندا بالطبع كانت
خاضعة منذ مئات السنين
لنظام استعماري فرضته بريطانيا وكان
ذلك النظام مشابهًا جدًا من حيث أنه
فرض سياسة حزبية وحشية جدًا جدًا
على الشعب الأيرلندي
وحاول بشكل فعال القضاء على
الثقافة الأيرلندية أه وطبعًا  أه كانت هناك
مقاومة كبيرة من
الشعب الأيرلندي ضد هذا
النظام الاستعماري العنصري أه وفي النهاية أدت إلى
الثورة في أيرلندا التي قامت
أه دولة مستقلة في معظم أنحاء
البلاد مع أن أيرلندا كانت مقسمة
ولذلك بقيت هذه القضية دون حل
فحتى اليوم هناك أه  توازيات
تشابهات قوية جدا حتى
يعرف الناس أن الشعب الفلسطيني
أيضا يواجه
نظام استيطاني استعماري أن هذا النظام مدعوم من
القوى الإمبريالية الكبرى أه وأه أن الفلسطينيين
هم الضحايا أه بالصدفة
بطرق عديدة كنت في فلسطين في أواخر عام 1987
في بداية الإنادا الأولى،
عملت فعليًا في إسرائيل غير مدرك
لمحنة الفلسطينيين حتى
بدأت العمل جنبًا إلى جنب مع الفلسطينيين
الذين كانوا
لاجئين والذين شرحوا لي عن
NABA حول كيفية انتزاع
ممتلكاتهم منذ عام 1948 ورأيت  عن نفسي
الطبيعة القمعية الوحشية
للنظام الإسرائيلي وهذا
أقنعني تمامًا بضرورة أن أكون نشطًا في
دعم الشعب الفلسطيني ولكن أه
كما قلت هذه تجربة شخصية
ولكن في أيرلندا كان هناك
تضامن كبير جدًا مع الشعب الفلسطيني
بسبب ذلك  التاريخ المشترك الذي
نتشاركه لذا فإن دور باريت
وسائل الإعلام الإخبارية مهم حقًا في
تشكيل الرأي العام كيف تنظر إلى
تصويرهم للحرب في غزة
أعتقد أنه أه نوع منحرف أه
أورويلية أه إذا كان مشاهدوك على
دراية بجورج  أورويل
وفكرته المزدوجة أه لأن
الصورة الشائعة مقلوبة أه تقدم
أه إسرائيل كدولة طبيعية إلى حد ما
والفلسطينيين الذين يقاومون ذلك النظام
كإرهابيين إلى حد ما بينما
الحقيقة هي العكس الذي
قامت عليه دولة إسرائيل  أساس
عمل الإرهاب والتطهير العرقي الضخم
عام
1948، واستمرت سياسة
الإرهاب والتطهير العرقي تلك ضد
الشعب الفلسطيني طوال
تاريخه، وما نشهده اليوم من
التهديدات المروعة التي
توجهها إسرائيل للأخلاق  إن تطهير
مليون فلسطيني من شمال غزة
هو ببساطة امتداد للسياسة
الإرهابية القاتلة والوحشية التي
تمارسها إسرائيل على الفلسطينيين منذ
عام 1948 أه لذا فهي ليست كما يحاول البعض
الإيحاء بها ونحن نسمع
هذه الكلمة في وسائل الإعلام  في الوقت
الذي يفترض فيه أن إسرائيل تدافع عن
نفسها بينما في الواقع هذا ليس
دفاعا عن النفس بل هو
هجوم إبادة جماعية حيث
يتم التعامل مع جميع سكان غزة
كأهداف مشروعة أه وهو
استمرار لعقود من الغزو العرقي
تطهير الاستيلاء على
الأراضي الفلسطينية من قتل الفلسطينيين مع
الإفلات من العقاب أه سجن
واحتجاز الفلسطينيين كرهائن دون
محاكمة في الاعتقال الإداري
وطبعا حصار غزة نفسه 17
سنة حصار وهو بكل تعريفه
جريمة ضد الإنسانية
وجريمة حرب أه هذا هو واقع إسرائيل
المزيد والمزيد من الناس العاديين في جميع
أنحاء العالم أصبحوا يدركون
القمع الرهيب للشعب الفلسطيني والواقع
الوحشي لما
هي الدولة الإسرائيلية أه وليس لدي
شك في أن العدالة أه  وتقرير
المصير سوف ينتصر في
النهاية، لكنها ستكون قوة الشعب،
وستكون مقاومة
الشعب الفلسطيني في جميع أنحاء
منطقة الشرق الأوسط بأكملها، وفي الواقع
تضامن الناس في جميع أنحاء العالم في
الدول الغربية و  في أماكن أخرى
يجبرون حكوماتهم أه على
محاسبة النظام الحزبي أخيرًا
لكني على ثقة من أننا
نستطيع تحقيق تلك الحرية والعدالة أه
وأخيرا إحلال السلام أه في منطقة
مبتلاة أه
بالتلاعب الإمبراطوري من القوى الكبرى
فلسطين ستتحرر من النهر إلى
البحر